clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci abonne toi
[Musique]
un repas d'affaires
un bate un dîner en ville une fête entre
amis dtc vous donne les moyens de
briller en société avec huit nouvelles
infos sur la santé que les gens ne
connaissent pas ces cadeaux c'est la
troisième et dernière tournée et on
commence tout de suite à l'aise
vous êtes déjà demandé pourquoi les
hommes ont des tétons alors qu'ils
servent à rien maintenant oui
pour comprendre il faut retourner dans
le vent de la mer non mais tu es tu
passé assez dégueu je vais vous raconter
plus tôt dans les 6,8 première semaine
du développement durable est il ya que
le chromosome x qui bossent celui qui
responsable du développement des
hormones et des organes sexuels femelle
le chromosome mal le gui gray qui se met
à dos et en dernier ouais même chez les
chromosomes c'est comme ça que ça se
passe donc au début on est tous
construits comme si on allait devenir
des femelles et qu'on allait avoir des
seins et apprécié chromosome y arriver
dit stop on arrête tout on va partir sur
un autre modèle
mais les tétons qui sont déjà refait
donc on les garde ceci dit dans l'absolu
les hommes ils sont capables de produire
du lait d'ailleurs renseignez vous
verrez il ya plusieurs cas qui ont été
décrits ou des hommes au moins l'été des
bébés comme quoi les histoires de gens
hommes femmes c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ce qu'on veut bien nous
raconter le partage des tâches pareil
on vous a tenu fallait pas gratté un
grain de beauté parce que ça peut donner
le cancer bullshit
ça veut dire qu'à cateau à grains de
beauté c'est un paquet de mélanocytes et
les mélanocytes cellules qui fabriquent
la mélanine c'est à dire le pigment qui
donne la couleur à notre peau c'est pour
ça qu'elles sont marron les cellules et
les grains de beauté aussi le goût c'est
vrai qu'un grain de beauté ça peut
dégénérer en cancer
grattez un grain de beauté ça le
transforme pas en cancer ca non
s'écorcher un grain de beauté non plus
même si ça saigne
enfin c'est pas plus dangereux que de
s'écorcher n'importe où en tout cas qui
peut craindre par contre c'est ici un
grain de beauté semaine à saigner tout
seul sans raison ou s'il change de forme
ou de couleur ou si il apparaît comme ça
tout d'un coup là il faut aller le
montrer un dermato de toute façon il
faut aller faire tenir régulièrement ses
grains de beauté chez un dermato c'est
important et mieux que le corsaire
les règles les menstrues rien que le mot
degers banon en fait non d'ailleurs
c'est quoi les règles en fait tous les
mois
en gros le corps il se prépare au cas où
il y aurait une fécondation
donc il se passe plein de trucs et par
exemple la paroi de l'utérus lcp ci
parce qu'a priori c'est par là que ça va
se passer
le corps prépare la chambre d'amis qui
vous voulez mais si y'a pas de
fécondation hop on range on nettoie tout
jusqu'à la prochaine fois et la paroi de
l'utérus elle redevient normale et en
faisant ça ça décolle la muqueuse qui
tapissent tout ça du coup ça saigne un
peu et ça coule par la seule sortie
disponible mais c'est juste du sens
normal avec les trucs qui a par là
d'habitude un peu de muqueuses les
bactéries de la flore vaginale etc
les trucs qui sont là tout le temps et
qui dérange personne en temps normal en
tout cas qui empêche personnes de venir
faire un tour dans le coin d'habitude
d'ailleurs non seulement les règles
c'est pas sale mais les rapports sexuels
pendant les règles c'est pas dangereux
là encore c'est pareil ça change rien à
d'habitude on n'est pas obligé si on n'a
pas envie mais c'est pas dangereux juste
se protéger de la même façon ni plus ni
moins
vous savez qu'on peut avoir à la dame
alors qu'on s'est fait amputer le bras
pareil pour les jambes et les dents et
la tête alouettes n'ont pas la tête
ça peut toucher n'importe quelle partie
du corps amputé ça s'appelle des
douleurs fantômes et sa touche 6 à 8
personnes amputées sur dix ça peut être
l'impression que le mans qui manque est
toujours là ça peut être des brûlures
des démangeaisons des fourmis d'écran et
ça peut aller jusqu'à des vraies grosses
douleurs
alors comment c'est possible un truc
pareil il ya plusieurs théories il y en
a qui pense que ça vient de notre
cerveau quand on pense à nos oreilles
par exemple il ya une zone dans nos
cerveaux qui s'allume et qui envoie un
message à nos orteils et normalement nos
orteils
ils répondent en envoyant un message
aussi et si ya pas de réponse le cerveau
il est perdu et ils essayent
d'interpréter ça avec des trucs qui
connaît alors une démangeaison une
brûlure des fourmis de la douleur mais y
en a aussi qui disent que c'est notre
corps qui essayent de reconstruire les
fibres nerveuses qui ont été coupées et
comme il n'y arrive pas à sa surcharge
le système et ça envoie une information
de douleur il ya plusieurs explications
mais si ça se trouve c'est un peu les
deux langues
en tout cas la bonne nouvelle c'est que
ça soit
remarquez que quand on n'arrive pas à
lire un truc on fait ça fermer les yeux
pour mieux voir si le louvre
bah non en fait c'est plutôt mal or
quand on regarde un objet c'est la
lumière qui se réfléchit dessus qui
rentrent dans nos yeux qu'est analysé
qui forment l'image qu'on voit et nous
surveillons en permanence en train de
s'adapter à la distance et à la quantité
de lumière pour que l'image soit net
un peu comme un appareil photo sauf que
des fois nos yeux ils ont du mal à faire
le pont
surtout de loin ou s'il ya trop de
lumière ou si on est myope ou vieux où
les deux chefs dans ces cas-là plisser
les yeux ça permet de rétrécir la porte
d'entrée donc de diminuer la quantité de
lumière qui rentre dans les yeux et de
bien là concentrée sur la rétine et
après c'est plus facile pour la rétine
de transformer la lumière en information
et de transmettre tout ça au cerveau oui
c'est son job à la rétine voilà donc
c'est un réflexe
et ça marche enfin dans une certaine
limite et puis si vous êtes obligé de le
faire trop souvent aller faire un petit
tour chez l'ophtalmo g
vous savez ce qui est deux fois plus
petit en hiver qu'en été un pénis oui
vous avez bien remarqué qu'ils ont
tendance à rétrécir quand il fait froid
et vous savez pourquoi pour vous sauver
la vie enfin la vôtre si vous en avez un
on sauve pas la vie des autres avec ses
machines
en fait ce qui se passe c'est que quand
la température extérieure baisse votre
corps fait plein d'efforts pour
maintenir sa température interne entre
36 et 37 degrés sans que c'est pour
protéger vos organes vitaux qui ont
besoin de chaleur genre votre coeur
c'est un organe vital mais le pénis
n'ont donc le corps pour éviter de
perdre de la chaleur par la circulation
du sang à la surface de la peau et
diminue la taille des vaisseaux sanguins
ça touche toutes les extrémités mais le
pénis il est pas comme le nez les
oreilles ou les doigts il a pas de
cartilage et il a pas dos c'est que des
tissus mous dans la plupart du temps des
tissus mous et de la peau et quand les
vaisseaux sanguins rétrécissent la peau
et se rétracte et le reste aussi
donc le pénis il vient tout petit il
faut savoir deux choses 1 avoir un petit
pénis c'est pas un problème c'est pas la
taille qui compte et deux y reprend sa
taille normale
avec la chaleur genre une douche ou
un petit coup de chaud
deux des poids lourds sera vraiment
aussi pas dégueu attendait pourquoi en
fait le problème des fois c'est qu'on en
a surtout dans les endroits où l'on sent
pas très bon à part ceux sur la tête et
autour de la bouche est encore autour de
la bouche ça dépend sous les bras entre
les jambes entre les fesses cerexhe a
toujours ouf
donc on a associé les poils aux
mauvaises odeurs mais en fait ils ont
rien à voir là dedans c'est juste qu'on
en a dans les plis et que ça a tendance
à macérer du coup les bactéries s régal
et ce qu'ils rejettent ça sent pas très
bon mais fois loupé à poil elles sont là
quand même les bactéries et
contrairement à ce qu'on pense les poils
ça fait pas transpiré plus haut niveau
ils viennent ça sert à rien de ses
filets faut juste la veille en fait
regarder à priori vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de poils au pied à sauf si vous
êtes un hobbit et pourtant si vous les
lavez pas et si on parle de la zone
génitale
vous savez où c'est se raser ou s'épiler
ça favorise les frottements les petites
blessures donc les infections les
mycoses et ça augmenterait même les
risques d'infections sexuellement
transmissibles
après garder ou enlever vos poils c'est
vous qui choisissez mais qu'on voit
qu'on ne pas que c'est sale c'est pas
vrai
noël j'adore ça la fête les décorations
les cadeaux art génial mais c'est
dangereux aussi contre la gastro la
gueule de bois se planter une artère en
ouvrant en huit ans parlait de l'ulcère
conçu à l'idée de passer la soirée avec
ton fachos et ya aussi le syndrome du
sapin de noël
et ouais c'est comme le rhume des foins
sauf que c'est pas aux pollens que vous
êtes allergique et aux sapins de noël
ah non pas vraiment ou sapin mais aux
moisissures et aux champignons qui a su
y en a même qui sont allergiques à la
neige artificielle et coupe aph le nez
qui coule on tousse ou on éternue et vu
qu'on sait qu'on risque de choquer le
coc vie pendant les fêtes ça peut faire
flipper et si vous avez les yeux qui
piquent et que ça vous gratte un petit
peu c'est plutôt une allergie donc fait
un saut chez le médecin pourra tueur pas
et votre sapin là que vous garder
longtemps plus il va y avoir des
moisissures dessus ça vous fait une
bonne raison pour pas attendre les
vacances de pâques pour jeter et joyeux
noël et à bientôt